i know i'm a little wasted
and all i want to say
and a little green
but
what i want to say is how much i am so
[ __ ] in love with you
thank you kris jenner delivers a tipsy
toast to remember but let's be real
chris probably doesn't remember it from
the day that i gave birth
so
come on
little busy
a wasted chris is the life of the party
as the fam rings in khloe kardashian's
38th birthday it's never a dull moment
at dinner chris raises her glass and
gives a speech honoring coco seems like
everyone at the table can't get enough
of the intoxicated momager
you are a rock star in my eyes you are
the queen of our family you are the
person who
is always looking at the left
at the glass
[Music]
who is
so amazingly beautiful while chris is
enjoying her fancy martini boyfriend
corey gamble thinks she's over served
and steps in to grab her drink and as
little sis kendall jenner put it in her
ig story i just can't with her and we
see why at one point chris's pal
intervenes in an attempt to get chris to
wrap things up i've had way too much to
drink tonight but
because we love you i know we're here
because you make our
[Music]
heart open is but they're coming
what
because she knows how i feel about you
and i can't control myself inside the
lavish dinner party kim kardashian also
catches tipsy chris on cam sneaking in a
smooch with her man corey seems like
courtney and travis aren't the only ones
packing on the pda these days wait look
look at them i can't really are no look
it's unbelievable
tune in because you never know what's
going to happen
and check this out we also get a rare
rob kardashian spotting yes coco's
reclusive baby bro walks by kim as she
poses for a selfie
it's nice to see the kardashian jinner
crew celebrating chloe after we saw how
they supported her amid the tristan
thompson paternity scandal that played
out on the family's hulu show chloe
she's the strongest girl i know
but sometimes the strongest girl you
know isn't so strong all the time and i
don't want her to get to a place where
she
you know
doesn't have anybody to talk to because
she feels like she has to be strong
as chris explained to e.t back in april
the family isn't holding back with this
new series
the episodes are more a little bit
documentary style and i think that you
have a real insight into what the girls
are doing not only you know what you see
in the press or whatever but what's
really happening behind the scenes still
gotta say nothing beats seeing this
tipsy toast from chris play out in real
time i can't control myself
she doesn't cry and i've had a couple of
drinks
[Music]